[Music]
we are very unusual as a species in that
not only do we have the capacity to
learn many species do this a fish in the
sea learns that if it swims towards the
light it will encounter prey there we
also have the capacity for social
learning which itself is unusual and
interesting that is we can learn from
each other and social learning is
extremely efficient for example I can
put my hand in the fire and learn that
that's hot and pull my hand out so I
have gotten some benefit of knowledge
but I've paid a price or I could watch
you put your hand in the fire get almost
as much benefit learning that fire is
dangerous and pay none of the price so
watching you and learning from you by
social learning and imitative learning
is extremely efficient but we not only
do that we teach each other we
affirmative ly set out to teach each
other stuff this is very rare in the
animal kingdom
in fact this aspect of our species lies
at the core of our capacity for culture
which is the capacity to transmit
knowledge across place and time so we
carry with us the benefits of all the
innovations and all the learning that
have been done by all prior members of
the human species carried forward unto
this day and when we learn something new
we transmit it laterally to two other
people this fundamental quality of
teaching also actually has political
implications because if we are actually
to effectively teach and learn from each
other we must create environments that
support free and open expression how are
we to learn from each other how are we
to acquire novel information
how are we to work together to establish
the truth of our environment if we don't
affirmative ly foster and support this
rather wonderful innate quality that we
have to teach and learn from each other
we are innately a friendly species but
we need environments which allow us to
optimally express our inclination to be
friendly we don't want for example
environments in which were pitted
against each other where we have leaders
that are kind of saying these people are
responsible for your problems we want
environments which say we can be United
common humanity and analogously we want
environments which are supportive and
conducive to teaching and learning we
want environments we want to create
environments in which we maximize the
flow and the spread of information some
of the most foundational liberties that
we have that are encapsulated in the
bill of rights by some kind of implicit
or deliberate insight by the founding
fathers actually speak to these
fundamental qualities that we evolved to
have for example the freedom of assembly
is enshrined in constitutions around the
world including ours the freedom of
speech is enshrined in our Constitution
and many others as well
these are innate desires that we have to
talk to and learn from each other to
assemble and connect with each other and
they are seen as fundamental political
principles and have been since our
founding
[Music]